[Musique]
mais bonsoir à tous le 7-8 journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition du mercredi 22 mai tout de suite
les titres c'est le laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales latmos à 10 ans implanté
notamment un but en cours il étudie les
processus fondamentaux régissant les
atmosphère terrestre et planétaire son
directeur est un ancien doctorant seront
en plateau 350 saint quentinois l'on
décerné ce mercredi à coignières le
troisième prix des collégiens électeurs
en poésie d'aujourd'hui a été remis à
lydia padellec son recueil cicatrices de
l'avant jours a reçu les faveurs des
lecteurs
enfin notre chronique cannoise du jour à
l'occasion du 62e festival du film au
programme ce soir isabelle huppert à la
fiche de francky en compétition
officielle et des nouvelles du duo
musical macadam crocodile une
information transport pour débuter la
région ile de france a décidé
aujourd'hui de suspendre sa subvention
au prolongement du rer e
un amendement a été voté ce mercredi la
raison la pollution de la senne par le
groupe vinci sur le chantier à ce jour
d'après la région vinci n'a pas fourni
la preuve d'un engagement irrévocable de
la remise en état de l'icco système
polluée pour rappel le rer e applis et
hall doit être prolongé à l'ouest de
paris 55 km de lignes supplémentaires
jusqu'à mantes la jolie
six cent cinquante mille voyageurs
devraient profiter de ces travaux et des
premières rames attendu pour 2024
cette actualité du jour aussi dont je
vous parlais dans les titres ce matin
350 élèves de saint quentin en yvelines
remettait le prix des collégiens
lecteurs de poésie d'aujourd'hui prix
organisé depuis trois ans sur le
territoire et c'est une auteure locale
qui a été désignée mélanie poker des
textes pensée est couché sur le papier
en 2015 lydia pas de lait qu'a voulu
transmettre ses pensées ses émotions sur
les événements tragiques parisien j'ai
pas écrit ce recueil pour un public
spécifique mais
c'est vrai que je pensais c'était un
petit peu difficile pour un public
collégiens et ils ont choisi sansan de
connaître en fait soit ça que c'est
encore vraiment plus plus important
puisque justement ils ne me connaissent
pas et c'est vraiment le texte qu'ils
ont choisie pour ce prix les dia pas de
lait qui était face à trois autres
ouvrages avec un jury inédit 350
collégiens saint quentinois
tout d'abord on a déclenché l'ouverture
et on a classé fondateur classement
provisoire des livres qu'on avait le
plus à celui qu'on aime et le mois
qu'après on à entrer dans le vif du
sujet on va regarder vraiment ce qu'ils
avaient dans le livre c'était sympa de
faire appel à des collégiens pour fort à
la poésie parce que souvent balles et
les jeunes et bae d'apps pas vraiment la
poésie et faire appel à des jeunes bat
c'est quand même assez original on en
apprend beaucoup des du poète fin
franchement c'est génial oui moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé comme ça j'ai découvert la
poète et beaucoup de livres le prix
collégiens lecteurs de poésie
d'aujourd'hui existe depuis trois ans
piloté par les itinéraires poétique
qu'il vise à diffuser la poésie
contemporaine
les ouvrages ont tous été édité
récemment fait un choix dans tout ce
qu'on reçoit ce ne sont pas des livres
destinés à la jeunesse c'est ça c'est
voulu et on fait un choix qui permettent
de montrer une l'éclectisme delà de la
création poétique mais aussi les
critiques de l'édition politique à
travers des ouvrages de forme va dire de
toucher différents aussi un travail
réalisé en cours ou lors d'ateliers les
collégiens ont aussi réalisé des vidéos
autour des textes étudiés quête ans
classes ont participé à cette troisième
édition
[Musique]
et on reparlera à la culture plus tard
dans ce journal
c'est une structure emblématique du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
le latmos fête cette année ses dix ans
de nombreux rendez vous organisés tout
au long de l'année dont une journée et
demain de présentation et de visites qui
se déroulera loubet est ce qu
l'observatoire versailles saint quentin
en yvelines alors pour parler de cet
anniversaire à deux invités avec moi en
plateau philippe qui écoute mon soir
vous êtes physicien et directeur du
latmos également vice-président de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
charge de l'innovation et des
partenariats industriels également avec
chloé françois mercier bonsoir vous êtes
ancien doctorant au latmos et vous êtes
co fondateur d'une start-up hd règne on
aura l'occasion d'en parler qui
travaillent encore avec le latmos alors
latmos pour laboratoire atmosphères
milieux observations spatiales il est
basé sur deux sites à guyancourt et
paris dix ans pour ce laboratoire
philippe but qu'est ce que ça représente
en disant c'est une étape parce que ces
dix ans que le laboratoire s'appelle
latmos mais c'est issus de laboratoires
quand écrasée dans les années 60
pionnier de l'instrumentation et
d'instruments station spatiale et donc
c'est une étape une étape importante
pour nous parce qu'un nouveau bâtiment
une implantation à le territoire avec
des nouvelles installations donc ça se
fait avec beaucoup de choses nouvelles
et et aussi du futur comment qui se
prépare
disons pour le latmos vous qui êtes
passé par le latmos vous êtes ancien
doctorant c'est une fierté d'être passé
au sein du latmos ah oui c'est
complètement une fierté on a réalisé des
recherches absolument passionnante
pendant trois ans là bas avec avec mes
directeurs thèse est tellement
passionnante qu'on a qu'on a continué
après sous forme de start up
alors si la présentation sur le site
internet du latmos il est spécialisé
dans l'étude des processus
physico-chimiques fondamentaux qui
régissent les atmosphère terrestre et
planétaire et ainsi que leur surface
ainsi qu'avec leurs interfaces avec la
surface l'océan et milieu
interplanétaire
on va essayer de vulgariser tout ça sur
quoi porte le travail du latmos alors en
fait c'est vrai que c'est une phrase un
peu compliqué mais c'est en fait pour
dire que on étudie l'atmosphère au sens
large c'est-à-dire aussi bien ce qui va
se passer au niveau de la surface que à
très haute altitude
voir l'impact du soleil sur saône sur
notre atmosphère et ça on va le faire
sur la terre
mais aussi sur les planètes du système
solaire donc du coup on a aussi une
approche de planétologie comparée qui
nous permet là du coup de comprendre au
delà de l'atmosphère terrestre
finalement qu'est-ce qui régit les
fondamentaux de l'évolution d'une
planète donc de l'observation alors il
ya une particularité c'est une forte
compétence e instrumental vous
construisez des instruments innovants
c'est ça qui sont déployés en alors ça
c'est vraiment une compétence qui est
historique 1
les laboratoires ont commencé avec des
fusées avec le premier satellite qui
était un satellite de télécommunications
france 1 et on n'a pas arrêté de
travailler sur le fait de faire des
instruments alors au sol en avion sur
ballon et dans l'espace et donc là on a
un partenaire privilégié bien sûr
qu'elle était le cnes l'agencé spatiale
française et l agence européenne les a
avec qui on construit on conçoit des
instruments et on les réalise
et certains sont réalisés donc
maintenant à guyancourt mais vous êtes
capable je croyais à un outil à la
pointe s'est notamment de recréer des
modèles numériques d'atmosphère c'est ça
alors on se fait des modèles numériques
pourrait se reproduire ce qui se passe à
la même manière que l'on produit la
météo ont reproduit finalement ce qui se
passe sur la planète mars ou vénus mais
mais mais peut-être encore plus proche
de la science fiction pour les gens
c'est qu'on reproduit chez nous de
manière réelle dans des enceintes les
atmosphères et on essaie de comprendre
comment ça quels sont les processus qui
sont un jour mission d'observation est
aussi une participation à de nombreuses
missions spatiales on a forcément être
aux états beaucoup de travail accompli
beaucoup de missions sur lesquels vous
avez participé
oui alors là le l'anniversaire
finalement vient sa levée des recherches
depuis longtemps parce qu'une mission
spatiale ça prend du temps mais on a le
satellite de lézat aeolus qui mesure le
vent appartenant d'un laser qui est un
concept développé par le laboratoire on
a la mission avec les chinois c'est faux
ça de mesures à la hauteur des vagues
avec des radars développer aux cèpes
hautement développées dans le
laboratoire on a la mission yasi pour la
pour la qualité de l'air qui a été aussi
correctement les processus par les
l'ailé les processus de traitement de
données ont été développés au
laboratoire et et ans et enfin
l'instrument fébus à bord de la mission
bepi colombo qui part pour mercure et
tout ça les derniers six mois donc
beaucoup de choses qui souhaite
finalement se concrétise la en cette fin
2018 et donc qui nous permettent
d'aborder 2019 de manière très très
content françois mercier par exemple sur
qu'est le projet vous avez pu travailler
vous au sein du latmos alors moi la
chose sur laquelle j'avais travaillé en
thèse et qui ensuite est devenu
l'entreprise c'est là une nouvelle façon
de mesurer la pluie c'est une façon
originale on utilise les ondes qui
viennent des satellites de télévision
le principe général c'est que ces
signaux qui arrivent tous les jours des
satellites sont atténuées affaibli par
les gouttes de pluie qui rend compte
quand ils traversent l'atmosphère
donc nous ont bien mesuré derrière des
paraboles commercial de télé la
puissance qui arrive du satellite
quand il pleut il ya une perte de
puissance et en mesurant cette perte de
puissance on arrive à déduire la pluie
et ont forcément la création de votre
start-up hd rennes où on imagine
scellier sur ce travail exactement
c'était là c'était la suite la poursuite
directe de ce travail
on avait bien avancé en thèse sur la
compréhension des phénomènes on était
capable de faire des produits quasiment
opérationnel et il y avait tout pour
faire une start-up le gros intérêt de
cette mesure c'est qu'elle est pas cher
en fait comparé aux autres moyens qu'on
utilise d'habitude pour mesurer la pluie
les radars et donc elle est très très
très très utile et très prometteuse pour
les pays en développement en particulier
qui ont rien actuellement pour pour
mesurer la pluie pour anticiper les
inondations éclair ce genre de choses et
ça va être une technologie très
importante dans les années à venir
aujourd'hui vous collaborez encore avec
lui latmos voilà alors aujourd'hui on
continue à collaborer donc inouïe nous
héberge il nous héberge depuis depuis un
an continue à avoir des discussions
scientifiques très régulière avec mes
directeurs thèse qui continue à bosser
sur des a travaillé sur des algorithmes
à la pointe pour faire ces traitements
là et c'est très précieux d'avoir cette
collaboration est d'être adossé comme ça
laboratoire pour lui pour rester à la
pointe des collaborations avec des start
up collaboration aussi au niveau
national international ça c'est aussi un
axe important pour le latmos les
collaborations dans la recherche ccc
fondamental alors ce qui est un peu
nouveau c'est que
le milieu académique avait tendance à
collaborer avec des laboratoires alors
de laboratoire aux niveaux national et
international ça fait très longtemps
qu'on travaille au niveau international
ce qui est un peu nouveau c'est le
partenariat avec le privé on en est au
début et nous on expérimente cela avons
avec des start up qui qui sortent
finalement de chez nous mais aussi avec
des entreprises qui veulent travailler
avec nous et on trouve un terrain
d'entente tout à fait intéressant le la
recherche académique peu de conduisant
la recherche amont et l'entreprise
finalement travaillant sur le produit et
là il ya vraiment une marge de
progression est de 2,2 de trouver des
des manière optimum de travail et qui
sont à vraiment à des frais chez qu'on a
commencé largement des péchés c'est
celle à la thématique de la journée de
demain
on a donc 60 partenaires qui viennent
nous on nous revoir donc des partenaires
avec qui on travaille depuis longtemps
des partenaires qui sont issus un petit
peu nos rangs et d'aider nouveau et on
espère que effectivement qu'on va faire
attraper le virus à tout le monde de
vouloir travailler avec le latmos et de
trouver une manière comme ça gagnent le
gagnant de travailler public privé très
rapide qu'on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler là il ya un projet futur pour
le latmos y un travail qui est fait sur
un âne ou satellite dont le lancement
est prévu fin 2020 2021 ses amis alors
ça a effectivement les nano satellites
c'est le résultat de la miniaturisation
des techniques et du coup aujourd'hui le
fait qu'on soit capable de faire des
mesures dans des satellites tout petit
çà çà çà çà çà change beaucoup la donne
parce que du coup on voit bien que on
peut être beaucoup plus autonome sur
l'espace et du coup ça change des
acteurs après avants ont travaillé du
mou travailler avec toutes les agences
nationales et internationales la nasa
roskosmos et en russie etc
aujourd'hui ça va changer un petit peu
avec les gaffes a qui vont prendre une
part importante dans ce jeu là et nous
on prépare l'avenir en ayant nous mêmes
une propre expertise sur le fait de
pouvoir lancer nous mêmes
des nano sciatique et ce premier on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler sur ce plateau
merci à philippe qu'écouter merci à vous
françois mercier pour ses 10 ans du
latmos et une journée qui est organisée
demain sur le site de l'ové est-ce qu à
guyancourt 46 associations yvelinoise
appel ce samedi 25 mai à marcher pour le
climat par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle le climat de notre
planète s'est réchauffée de plus de un
degré le niveau des océans pourrait
monter de deux mètre d'ici 2100 si rien
n'est fait sur le sujet alors l'objectif
de cette première marche organisée à
saint quentin en yvelines est d'alerter
sur d'alerter les pouvoirs locaux sur
cette urgence climatique le départ est
fixé à 10 heures 30 devant la gare de
montigny le bretonneux et les propos
sont requis par marylène yapi chinois
nous aurons un itinéraire de deux
kilomètres de marche calme paisible
familiale qui aura pour but d'inciter
les gens à nous suivre dans cette
initiative pour le climat contre le
réchauffement climatique et pour les
initiatives locales
justement pour essayer d'agir
efficacement contre le réchauffement
climatique et le climat qui serait au
coeur de l'émission à 7,8 débat de ce
soir c'est à retrouver après ce journal
sur tv 78 les acteurs de l'immobilier
d'entreprise présents mardi soir à
elancourt à la commanderie une réunion
pour dresser le bilan et surtout évoqué
l'avenir de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines dans ce domaine est
le reportage de wilfrid richier patrick
jacques de dixmude 222 1500 mètres
carrés de mouvements d'entreprise sur
saint quentin en yvelines pour 2018
une année record et les perspectives
pour cette année et les suivantes sont
plutôt encourageantes
la performance de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est justement d'avoir
une représentation de pratiquement
toutes les filières d'excellence que ce
soit l'aéronautique défense sécurité
l'automobile smartcity banque assurance
finance si on a une filière qui ne
fonctionne pas très bien on a quand même
toutes les autres filières avec tous les
bureaux d'études qui vont qui vont bien
qu'ils suivent qui suivent ces filières
le rendez vous des acteurs de
l'immobilier qui se tenait elancourt
cette semaine a notamment été l'occasion
d'évoquer des secteurs à enjeux dont le
pôle high tech sur le secteur
d'elancourt plaisir les clayes-sous-bois
et rap
nous avons des entreprises très haute
valeur ajoutée ici on a été encore
classé dans les sur le top 10 des
entreprises qui créent le plus de
brevets
il y en a 5 sur les dix dans le top 10
mais qui sont à 50 un autre projet
présenté la sttr dans le quartier du pas
du lac le promoteur réalité va réaliser
dès le mois d'octobre trois bâtiments
ce sera sa première réalisation dans
l'agglomération on est en train de
préparer un très beau projet très
innovant à la fois dans sa forme et son
sa conception architecturale et puis
dans la maîtrise des usages qu'on essaye
de mettre en place
l'immobilier d'entreprise sur saint
quentin en yvelines représente plus de 4
millions et demi de mètres carrés sur
l'ensemble des douze communes avec des
typologies très différente de la tpe aux
grands groupes
[Musique]
vous avez sûrement a reconnu sur ce
sujet la voix d'aurélie rose parenthèse
politique dans ce journal avec nos
questions aux candidats aux européennes
le scrutin est programmé ce dimanche ce
soir c'est jean pierre mercier qui se
prête à l'exercice ouvriers automobiles
dans les yvelines il est deuxième de la
liste lutte ouvrière ses réponses au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude on
appelle les travailleurs les chômeurs
les retraités du monde du travail à à
voter pour la liste lutte ouvrière pour
faire entendre le camp des travailleurs
face à la grande bourgeoisie face au
grand capital
cette grande bourgeoisie ultra
milliardaire s'accapare toutes les
richesses de la société se comporte
comme un rouleau compresseur
sur l'ensemble de la société puis un
train de vie de luxe avec la peau des
travailleurs il faut que dans ces
élections les travailleurs fassent
entendre leur intérêt leur intérêt de
travailleurs et met en avant des
objectifs de lutte pour défendre leurs
conditions de vie
l'europe peut pas protéger les
travailleurs l'europe elle protège les
capitalistes elle protège les
milliardaires
elles protègent les riches les seuls qui
pourront protéger les travailleurs c'est
des travailleurs eux mêmes par leur
lutte par leur mobilisation par la force
social qu'il représente
quand ils se mettent en bagarre quand
ils se mettent en grève on milite pour
que les travailleurs prennent en main
leur destin et défendre leurs intérêts
par la lutte le changement ne viendra
que par le bas jamais par le haut c'est
un faux débat
c'est même plus qu'un faux débat c'est
un piège qui est étendue à la fois par
ceux de macron qui pensent que l'europe
et fraternelle et solidaire ça c'est un
mensonge tout comme les le pen ou les
houles et où les mélenchon qui sont anti
européen les travailleurs doivent se
faire entendre en tant que travailleur
si la france devait quitter l'europe
c'est les travailleurs qui devrait payer
la note si la france doit rester en
europe c'est les travailleurs qui paient
la note
ma nous on veut que ça soit les
milliardaires on veut que ça soit la
grande bourgeoisie qui paye la note
on en a marre nous les travailleurs les
chômeurs les retraités de payer pour les
riches
l'ensemble de nos trois questions aux
candidats aux européennes c'est à
retrouver sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme et puis larges pages
culturelles dans ce journal depuis plus
de 20 ans la ville d'andrésy célèbre
l'art et la nature la 22e édition de
sculptures en l'île vient de débuter
jusqu'au mois de septembre vous pourrez
découvrir de nombreuses oeuvres sur les
quatre lieux de l'exposition découverte
signé marylène iapichino et nicolas
landry artistes nationaux et
internationaux se retrouve à andrésy
depuis 22 ans
il célèbre la nature à travers leurs
oeuvres originales
chaque année nous essayons d'amener de
nouveaux artistes de nouvelles visions
de nouvelles perspectives
mais en même temps on est toujours dans
cette continuité de célébrer ce rapport
à la nature
la maison du moussel se voit relié au
sophora japonais voisins à eux deux ils
forment une seule et même oeuvre dans
laquelle s'expriment les souvenirs des
habitants
les arbres engrange la mémoire du monde
il a gardé dans sa mémoire tous les
souvenirs de larmes de joie et de larmes
de chagrin des habitants d'andrésy donc
nous sommes allés enquêter dans les rues
un peu au hasard en eau d'andrésy en bas
d'andrésy une installation esthétique
mais aussi sonore à l'extérieur et à
l'intérieur de la maison
ils ont créé ces perles avec ces mots
d'andré zia je trouve c'est vraiment
plein d'émotions j'étais mal vraiment
scotché
je reconnais pas par cet homme plus loin
les sculptures d'une artiste suisse
laisse le soleil les mettre en mouvement
et j'essaie de transmettre en plus de la
nature aussi un certain optimisme parce
que les couleurs pures c'est quand même
ça ça donne de la force dynamique un
optimisme transmis au maire d'andrésy
qui inaugurait sa dernière édition
il espère que son successeur fera
perdurer cette poésie encore longtemps
allez c'est l'heure de notre escapade
cannoise dans ce journal
[Musique]
le festival de cannes ce n'est pas que
du cinéma l'événement est aussi réputé
pour ses nuits l'une d'elles a été
animée une nouvelle fois par des
yvelinois macadam crocodile s'est
produit vendredi dernier dans l'une des
soirées les plus sélects de la croisette
nous les avions a suivi il y a un an
depuis le groupe a enregistré son
premier album en live c'est la réunion
de deux amis vincent et xavier ont
fréquenté le même lycée dans leur
jeunesse à la celle saint cloud après
des carrières respectives dans la
musique les yvelinois se retrouvent et
font de macadam crocodiles le duo était
de retour à cannes pour se produire dans
l'une les soirées du 72e festival comme
il ya un an c'était sur la terrasse du
fife si de terre c'est toujours sympa de
venir parce que on croise plein de gens
qu'on ne voit pas forcément pendant
qu'on est en tournée il ya plein d'amis
musiciens la comen et d'intelligent ya
plein de gens qu'on croise sur la route
et puis voilà il ya un petit esprit
festif qui peut bien correspondre à
mcadam d'une certaine manière dont en
plaçant non mais la musique a clairement
sa place à cannes et ont notamment dans
les soirées
mcadam crocodile c'est un style basé sur
des prestations en live mêlant chant 100
et instruments le tout au rythme de
l'électro du new disco et de l'afro funk
cette année le groupe a franchi une
étape dans son projet un album a été
enregistré en avril dans un club
parisien
au lieu de se dire on va sortir un album
de manière un peu classique on s'est dit
que ce qui correspondrait peut-être
mieux c'était d'enregistrer en fait un
live et de cela est que ce soit l'album
en fait et donc c'est ce qu'on a fait au
mois d'avril le 11 avril on arrose trio
badaboum à paris à paris et on était
très très sûr plier ses sapins fois
qu'on veut une salle en tête d'affiche
et on ya vraiment une led la dû répondre
y avait on avait un super accueil voyez
une monde qui est venu cet album en live
devrait sortir d'ici la fin de l'année
ou début 2011 comme chaque soir jusqu'à
demain hugo casadamont de radio
sensations depuis cannes pour continuer
de nous faire vivre ce festival on le
retrouve tout de suite univie noises à
l'honneur lors de ce 62e festival de
cannes sète isabelle huppert qui joue
dans le film frankie d'arras axes
proposés en compétition un film grâce
auquel le réalisateur prétend gagner et
remporter la palme d'or ici alors je
vous le rappelle isabelle huppert a
commencé dans les yvelines sa carrière
théâtrale à versailles alors dans ce
film isabelle huppert incarne une
célèbre actrice française qui se s'est
gravement malade et qui risquent de
mourir dans quelques mois vous propose
de l'écouter tout de suite et de voir
les premières images du film
[Musique]
ayew from tv qui vous nouerez picano ce
film et sur la maladie sur la mort sur
une personne en fin de vie mais tout le
film dans son traitement est loin de
cela il n'est jamais mélodramatique
il n'y a pas grand signe visible de
cette maladie fait la triste oui tu n as
tu accèdes pas et fait passer comme des
strips
pour tous des femmes et des hôpitaux
tout sur moi il m'a donné l'opportunité
de montrer la maladie le désespoir de
montrer ce qui se passe dans l'esprit
quand vous vivez ce genre de situation
filmon de manière très réglée mais très
forte parce que la caméra est capable de
capter des petits moments des moments
fin pour les rendre très grand c'est le
pouvoir du cinéma rendre l'infiniment
petit un fini mon grand c'est vraiment
ça la définition du cinéma et de la
réalisation des chaînes home cinéma
enfin le zoom du jour sur un film
financé par la région ile-de-france
portrait de la jeune fille en feu est en
compétition dans la sélection officielle
du festival de cannes
il est réalisé par céline sciamma
l'intrigué prend racine dans le xviiie
siècle français et 1770 marianne une
pente raide doit réaliser le portrait de
mariage d'eloïse cette jeune femme qui
vient de quitter le couvent résiste à
son destin des poules en refusant de
poser
marianne va être alors introduite comme
femmes de compagnie pour la peindre en
secret je vais aller à la messe vous
voulez communier je peux entendre de la
musique alors que c'est beau mais c'est
la musique des mois c'est le seul que je
connaisse
on n'avait jamais entendu un arc à
poulies
racontez moi
ce n'est pas facile de raconter la
musique
[Musique]
avant de refermer ce journal la
librairie du pavé du canal a fait
plaisir aux enfants le week-end dernier
le commerce de montigny le bretonneux un
invité en exclusivité l un des héros de
leur livre jeunesse choupi on part à sa
rencontre avec marylène iapichino
nicolas nombre et c'est avec des étoiles
plein les yeux que les petits saint
quentinois ont répondu à l'invitation de
leurs personnages préférés
t'choupi pour les 30 ans de la librairie
le pavé du canal il est venu rencontrer
ces jeunes lecteurs impressionné et je
les regarde le ciel at elle les effets
des vessies il a son propre dessin animé
mais son succès vient d'une série de
livres jeunesse illustré par thierry
courtin schouppe il y raconte ses
aventures du quotidien des fois on a des
enfants par exemple ils sont peu peur
d'aller à l'école où ils ont peur de
quitter tôt d'où ils ont peur de quitter
la tétine et tout ça et puis bah avec
les livres ben moi je partage avec eux
ce qui m'est arrivé une lépi comme ça y
est c'est plus facile pour eux
les enfants et leurs parents étaient
nombreux ce héros des petits remporté un
réel succès bien plus que notre
journaliste que tu peux me dire ton nom
et ton âge
un joli souvenir pour les saint
quentinois qui repartent chacun avec une
dédicace et une nouvelle photo de
famille c'est la fin de ce journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
oh
[Musique]